I'm surprised grant hasn't been executed
and stuffed after that last Ice Age
movie made wait a minute that last Ice
Age movie made over 400 million
worldwide
that's insane what is wrong with the
world now these two big doors the
entrance to the outside area for these
bulls are humans aware in this world
that animals have humanistic qualities
because if so just having them fight
Matadors seems less profitable than
taking advantage of the other skills
they possess the paella is still almost
completely full even after the water was
seen pouring out of it and at one point
the bucket even turned upside down and
if this was all the water Ferdinand was
going to pour on the flower why fill the
pail up all the way in the first place
you're never gonna get selected you want
to know why why who knew even in the
world of Bulls there are bullies bullies
well let me try something out bullies
Balai belligerent bowls in belize
astonishing excuse me guys I've got an
ancient Mayan ruin to find it's at this
point as a human being I would wonder
why all these Bulls are looking at me
expectantly and why one of the Bulls
looked proud while the other seems upset
he wasn't picked gotta come back right
what that Matador doesn't stand a chance
okay really curious what exactly the
Bulls thought processes in this world
movie makes it clear that no other bull
comes back after fighting the matador so
why do either of them think the dad will
be back the humans around here seem
awfully trusting of the bowls to get in
the transport all by themselves for
advanced pop could easily take out this
lone stable worker here and run for the
hills
Ferdinand uses his newly found human
muscles to hoist himself over the fence
that is meant to keep him in damn eight
minutes and forty-five seconds is all it
took for this movie to steal the line
came from Bambi late-night Mystery Train
just happens to be leaving right now
so that firk man can leave the ranch
seriously why is this train here and why
does it need to leave right now this
railroad builders would stop leaving
conveniently placed ramps along the
tracks city and animal train crushing
antics would go down by at least 67% hey
Gus I was wondering something how did
that bull know to jump onto that train
like that you think these willows might
be self-aware I'll take good care of you
Burton and somehow winds up by the one
farm that would probably take him in
over just returning him to the Casa del
Toro I mean there's only so many places
he could have wandered off from right
how did they know his name was Ferdinand
I wasn't like he was wearing a collar or
any kind of identification tags the
director said let's have your character
effect to be given an apple that Nina's
asshole dad was about to eat it'll make
you look like even more of an asshole
funny gag I guess but now the hell did
he get inside the house
also the couch survives this heyyyyy
wait a minute
don't caterpillars have to go through a
series of developmental stages called
instars and then go through a few
patient ritual and some kind of molting
involved I don't know can catalogs
really do that guys I think I've hid
terminal sinning what this montage
proves beyond a shadow of a doubt is
that furred man causes more damage than
a fun bull normally does a scientist is
ecstatic wired to turn this cart into a
trampoline Nina really should have died
from this movie attempts to explain
Ferdinand's comings and goings to and
from this house but movie is wrong a dog
and a bull can't be brothers that would
be weird
that's brotherís Ferdinand can't come to
the festival this year this is the only
movie in memory that has ever had a
flower living bull get adopted by a
chicken farmer whose daughter likes to
go to flower festivals with her pet bull
who is suddenly too old to go and makes
that a major plot point but he goes with
us every year I know but he's not a
little calf anymore but he was a little
calf the previous year I'm no expert in
the amount of time it takes a bull to
grow but I'm guessing he was at least
half this size last year and therefore
too large for them to take him to the
festival my mother always told me that
if I'm ever in a dark alley sniffing
flowers that's probably an indication
that I have a problem someone get that
ice cream an agent because it has
perfect dramatic timing Ferdinand hasn't
tried to hide the entire time since he's
gotten to the festival but he or he
randomly does by pretending to be a
balloon so far everyone in this village
has reacted to Ferdinand with mild
fright which means I'm guessing they can
recognize his kind eyes and facial
expressions even though the bull part of
the equation still causes some alarm
movies got a movie and all but they
couldn't come up with something better
than this - cause Ferdinand to freak out
and be forced back to Casa del toral as
big as he is this small bee sting would
be nothing more than a small prick baby
in a life-threatening situation just
loves nearly dying because it's baby
brain hasn't registered the concept of
cruel death cliche
yep movie couldn't resist putting its
bull in a china shop shop owner would
display their glassware like this a
regular-sized human would be not all
over the place if they tried to walk
through the store hey big guy named Lupe
I'm gonna be your common goat or you can
just call me dory
also while calming goats exist they are
mostly used for horses and I'm not sure
I understand why they're used for Bulls
especially fighting once isn't being all
revved up and wanting to run their horns
through stuff kind of the point some
sharp a small piece ting sense Ferdinand
into a rage that gets him in this
predicament but he falls on Lupe sharp
horns and nothing we can in dial it up
to 11 might be way too much kate
mckinnon you're the bull who destroyed a
whole village right did the owner of
this ranch discuss all the details of
Ferdinand's adventure around Lupe before
he got here
I can't wait to show you off to the rest
of the guys they're gonna fertilize the
young along from a 2017 children's film
I am not intimidated by your freakish
hugeness you think they just ask Peyton
Manning for things he's said in the
huddle to come up with his dialogue I
don't know you but I'm not scared of ya
yeah sorry sack of meat first rule of
comedy when all else fails introduce a
character with a Scottish accent and oh
yeah doctor who is that anyway
oh I get it because I'm small you know
what you are a sizes bone stole our sin
it'll make me look even better when I
beat you to a pulp inside the ring
welcome back Ferdinand how exactly is
Valiente still here based on the lack of
competition with bones Guapo and the
bull who can't see shouldn't he have
been picked by a matador already look
was Lupe just keeping that down in fact
until the right moment presented itself
also it's been 22 years since Macarena
was released
can we not confine some other Hispanic
anthem to use when one is needed are you
trying to steal my stuff oh hey it's the
hyenas from The Lion King I mean the
gargoyles from The Hunchback of Notre
Dame I mean the Penguins from Madagascar
my greatest fear is a heart attack while
watching a regurgitated children's film
and that being the last thing I see in
this life like butter
who knew Gabriel Iglesias was a discount
Josh GAD I'm Oona I'm DOS and I'm Quatro
Oh what happened at race
we do not speak of this this is the
funniest bit in the movie which would
make one think that we should take a sin
off but this is the funniest bit in the
movie movie officially hits new
character overload and every single one
of them is annoying
how long was Ferdinand gone from this
ranch that's an incest joke right there
if the wall didn't make a loop a shape
on the side and which she hid it then
why would it make one on the other side
of the wall my hunts are my instruments
us are my arms next chest feet and vitex
this movie shows that when in doubt
throw a button to the conversation you
can't miss I would lose may come out
into the ring this would not be a
situation where they would need a calm
and goat come on and there's zero chance
el primero would pick bones right so why
send him out there luckily for this bull
ranch the Bulls know that they're going
to try out and know to run after a
stationary red cape even though we all
know it's the movement of the cape and
not the color that gets Bulls all riled
up also this ranch has really changed up
the criteria for bull tryouts haven't
they last time it was simply two Bulls
fighting each other now it's hitting
this mad a dummy in addition to some
sort of free-for-all Unreal Tournament
battle arena my fighting out fight is in
two days if I do not find the best bull
for the best bull fighter by then no
bull fighter will ever use your ranch
again
luckily the best bull fighter in the
world has decided this is the only ranch
in all of Spain where he can find the
best bowl so that the movie confer
Danann for the next hour so even though
this truck is only going to drive about
a hundred yards to the Chop House on
this very ranch this picture on the back
helpfully illustrates the fate of the
passengers so the characters know what's
up taking guap to the Chop House well
that's not so bad
they actually serve reasonably priced
lunches and oh this is a children's film
right there's a lot of lot of pollen in
the air this time of year that's right a
lot of pollen I know I know
what's animated and there's animals
talking and we could play this game
every since video for these types of
films but how the fuck do they know what
pollen is or allergies
obstacle course look alive f-stop we got
24 hours to whip you into shape for el
primero Lupe was not around when el
primero gave his ultimatum and therefore
would have zero clue how much time they
had to do anything at least this movie
doesn't have one of those ridiculous
slow-motion shots in the air where the
character is saying whoa and trying not
to hit something likes a funny
thankfully Ferdinand remembers his CPR
training from that summer camp two years
prior give me a fucking break
angus has always known this was his
problem earlier when Kenny goat told him
that he was talking to Ferdinand's but
he blew his hair up so he could see
better it's impossible for this asshole
not to know that was the problem and
impossible he wouldn't have done
something about it by now a boy dancing
I know these horse characters are
supposed to be annoying but they might
be the most unwelcome secondary
antagonist since the Joker in Suicide
Squad yah Weiner schnitzel you
pasty-faced glow stick that's racist and
Aquinas yep it was only a matter of time
until this movie about bullfighting
resorted to a dance-off which is the
only way to settle scores and movies
nowadays next up will be the Avengers
infinity war which will feature your
Thanos and Captain America serving each
other in a disco murder tech also this
bull horse dance-off goes on for some
time and movie has time for this also
why are the horses in this movie they
already have the humans namely the
matador set up pretty well as the
antagonist and you have the hedgehogs
for comic relief
so what purpose - the horses serve other
than to make an over long movie even
longer let's see five sins for the bad
pun and ten sins for the outdated
reference I mean where's the beef y'all
where's the beef dance why can't we just
agree that they all can dance and why
can't we just agree that this is the
most oblivious ranch in all of the world
the owner is sitting on a cold mind with
animals that act like people from live
shows to YouTube to scientific grants
they'd be making way more than they are
trying to sell bulls to Matadors and
let's not forget the merchandise our
only way out is to beat the matador in
the ring it's funny you should mention
that because it looks like there's an
easy way out just behind you shirt
Ferdinand ran into the electric fence
earlier but this spot behind Valiente
looks very escapable add to that I'll
say again it's the most oblivious ranch
in the world
what does Valiente think they will do
with him after he beats the matador just
let him go live in a mansion or
something me through there uh have you
seen these hips y-yes I also saw you
walk through this door earlier and you
managed to sleep in Nina's room despite
the high degree of difficulty there so
why would this be any different both I
couldn't all that if any longer is this
a car or is it a toy car
sure Ferdinand is going to get stuck in
it but it looks like a human would get
stuck in it too
and why did the cars lights and radio
come on when Ferdinand crash-landed into
it okay all right we got to do something
guys this works this guy seems to always
be outside when something happens
between the Bulls I wonder if he
witnessed that dance-off earlier that
one is the best war I'll fight human
Matthew tomorrow I get this isn't like
boxing where the fighters have to train
for months but they still have to sell
tickets to the matador show if he hadn't
found a bull by the next morning what
was el primero as plan for the event
everyone is coming to Jesus they're
taking Valiente to the Chop House
already this is one of those 24-hour
ranches where people are always on the
job no matter what time and still don't
notice bulls running obstacle courses
sure why do anything smart for your
escape like this couldn't have been done
with it done to rubber gloves the
hedgehogs could have done this for you
its Guapo Guapo is still alive what was
the rush and sending Valiente here then
I guess those trucks with the meat
diagrams on the back of them are really
just for dramatic effect wait a minute
are you telling me this motion sensor
laser thing doesn't really set off an
alarm it just starts the meat grinding
machines or is this just an over-the-top
security system complete with death
traps
Valiente ex machina but I'm more pissed
off that the bull named machina
wasn't the ex machina thanks for uh
power pawns dicks we're trying to help
you well you're doing a terrible job
Guapo somehow avoid the death traps that
Ferdinand and Valiente need a team work
to avoid Jesus Christ luckily that large
boulder of ice that was sure to
suffocate all of them turned out to be
so easily breakable this is the second
time untrained animals have to perform
CPR on a bunny and I have yet to see any
Flatliners types Oh dogs up how does the
character name bones not get this line
Makana ex machina there is hope in the
world by the way this is at least the
third movie in the last couple years to
have animals driving cars finding dory
the secret life of pets is this
mandatory nowadays
oh damn wouldn't you know just the luck
they chased after their runaway Bulls on
the day the interstate was reduced to
one lane and that somehow didn't slow
down all the traffic on this road at all
and now they're paying the price sure
this guy notices the Bulls driving the
truck but how did nobody else in Madrid
see this - they're in bumper-to-bumper
traffic let's go let's go what what are
you planning to do commandeer the truck
with a bunch of self-aware animals you
don't even have a cattle prod or
sedatives or anything that will help you
if you reach them there was a discussion
in a room at one point where someone
said you know what this movie needs they
rap that samples soup dragons and
someone else agreed yeah that's pretty
funny and all but why is the bus even
still driving seems like the situation
would call for bus drivers to stop make
a few phone calls flag down an officer
of the law or something but maybe Spain
is different oh I want to die looking at
you but you know what's really annoying
is that this movie finds ways to say but
a lot but not enough for a bonus rep Liu
Bei knows how to train tracks work Apple
ass holy reassigned
there are really only two foods depicted
in this movie carrots and apples okay
this guy have a power bar or a box of
animal crackers with the climactic chase
scene I think this movie has hit every
animated movie cliche in the book so
they dragged Ferdinand all the way back
to the city to load him into the trailer
instead of just bringing it to the train
tracks you are the bravest bull I know
but you're gonna have to fight and
Ferdinand who has never actually fought
going up against el primero who has
never lost will somehow find a way to
win you don't have to do anything kids
accept anything you want and everything
will work out just fine you know I'm
happy that Ferdinand is winning this by
not fighting at all
but the idea that he's not surrounded by
all the picadors who stick the bull with
Lance's is pure fantasy
you interrupt this bull fight to show
you that Ferdinand really loves his
flowers in case you didn't know that
from the first 90 minutes of this movie
this guy lets his daughter go down into
the arena sure Ferdinand isn't a threat
but what about security is there any
security at these places I mean I guess
everyone here knows that Nena and
Ferdinand have a relationship and is
going to allow this oh man I'm so happy
that Nena and Ferdinand got back
together what do you I think the wedding
will be like and in gay
aged fully entertained Spanish crowd
enables Ferdinand's nasty flower
addiction our bull DB original title of
the movie suey
the ranch owner just let Nina have these
bulls how nice of him he must have
learned some lessons along the way that
we're all off screen it's probably
something to be said about this scene
they stuck in the middle of the credits
but I'm just stupefied how they found
room for yet another apple and carrot
into this picture Jesus draw something
else and yeah I see the radish and the
penis emoji just do something else damn
it Harry
the meat is filthy do you know they got
untrained people working in the gut
table in the time he could stand he was
baptised in the fire of combat taught
never to retreat never to surrender but
the death on the battlefield in service
to Sparta
they lived only to face a new nightmare
the war against the machines nothing
gets past us never ever never forever
forever ever ever
there'd be a bunch of choppy crushy
things in the middle
[Music]
and the eighth and final rule if this is
your first night if I Club you're gonna
have to fight cuz today is Rex Manning
day okay I don't know your men could be
anything I'll be Stern ease inflexible
Tina lazy susan